Das war's für heute.
one
two
one toe
one
two
Das war's für heute.
Um so etwas zu gimmen,
um so etwas zu gimmen,
um so etwas zu gimmen.
und so weiter.
Und das war's für heute.
In diesem Video
Das war's für heute.
Wir erzählen direkt, genau.
Ich habe hier eine Windows 98 ISO und mein Ziel ist es unter Windows 98
Warum hat XQC auch so ein Old Emote? Ich dachte nur ich hätte so ein Old Emote
aber ich aber ich finde ich finde mein Old Emote besser
Heute eine Runde ins Online Casino, ja genau, paar Runden Slotten Schienen
Also ich habe heute vor Windows 98 zu installieren und dann schauen was wir damit auf die Reihe gehen
Also das erste Ziel ist, und dann will ich als erstes mal probieren, dass wir das überhaupt
Also wir machen das in der VM, ich habe hier noch einen Rechner, ich wollte es erst da probieren
Problem ist nur ich habe keine originale CD und Windows 98 von USB zu installieren
Das ist ein bisschen größer Akt, das mache ich wenn das in der VM gut funktioniert
Was wir alle nicht wissen, magst du ihm aber dann live von der Arbeit, ich verrate nicht alles
Zumindest will ich mal gucken, dass wir ein aktuelles Video abgespielt bekommen
Nehme ich mein letztes Gameplay
Was spackt denn das hier so rum?
Ich will mal probieren, das erste wir probieren jetzt, ob der ein aktuelles Gameplay hat,
und zwar das ist nicht ein Gameplay, das ist das letzte Gameplay was ich im Video verwendet habe
Das ist allerdings ein h264 mpeg 4 60 fps 720p Video, das ist ungefähr 15 Jahre neuer als Windows 98
So, dann will ich mal gucken, dass wir einen halbwegs aktuellen Browser drauf kriegen,
mal gucken was der aktuellste Browser ist den wir drauf kriegen
Wie nimmst du das denn aktuell auf?
Achso, Konsole mit der LG Ato und Windows halt alles auf dem PC mit Shadowplay
Im Handy genau
So und dann gucken wir was wir sonst noch so unter Windows 98 machen können
So mal gucken, also als erstes installieren wir den Krampel mal
Irgendwie ich mein es ist 1542, aber ich bin nicht müde ich weiß auch nicht warum
Vielleicht liegt das auch an der Musik, vielleicht ist die Musik auch einfach zu relaxen
Ich weiß nicht ob man davon wacher wird, das ist eigentlich eher ne Runde mehr cringe
Wir machen wieder Relaxing Piano an
Was ist besser Firefox oder Mozilla Firefox?
Mozilla, ne wie heißt das Ding?
Ach fuck jetzt hab ich's vergessen, dieser Mozilla Mobile Ding, wie hieß der Kram?
Die haben doch so ein extra Privacy Mobile Browser
Klar, genau, klar, was kein Mensch benutzt irgendwie
Okay also, ach ne die Musik das geht echt nicht, da schlaf ich ein bei
Ja dann irgendwie sowas
Okay auf gehts hier, so Windows 98, komm an brah
Wir müssen jetzt Flick Aim den Next Button
Funktioniert nicht
NAA, können wir einfach Enter drücken, ne geht nicht, hier nochmal
Wir wollen Windows 98 haben, aber richtig
Next, Next, 512, komm, gehen wir Windows 98 ordentlich ramm, natt, jawoll, Next, Next,
Next, 8G reichen, Next, Next, das ist ja super, Hi etwa, anster Wizard er, Finish, so, jetzt
CD einlegen, ESO, da, Windows 98, BÄM, Power on, huge, so, I finished Installing auf jeden
Fall, jetzt müssen wir erstmal ein, stretch guest, free stretch und von CD starten, Setup
von CD starten, auf gehts, 512MB, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das Windows 98 überhaupt
erkennt, Maximum, willkommen, RAM 830G, echt, stand das da, Monochrom, ganz wichtig, den
Dark Mode im Installer einschalten, die war in ihrer Zeit schon voraus, die haben schon
quasi den Dark Mode eingebaut im Windows 98, was ich witzig finde, man kann nicht mehr
rückgängig machen nachdem er es einmal eingeschaltet hat, so, Next, Next, ja, Large, Large,
Diskette, wollt ihr mich verarschen Microsoft, Alter, es geht bestimmt auch so weiter, BÄM,
von CD starten, Setup von CD starten, kommt wahrscheinlich wieder das gleiche, BÄM, funktioniert,
kein Problem, einfach nur jibated wieder, einfach nur jibated, der Computer wird jetzt
eine Routineprüfung unterzogen, dann viel Spaß, oh, dieser Sound, Huge Sound, Omega Sound,
in deinem Google News viel eine super Nachricht gelesen, aber was denn für eine, okay weiter,
ich meine, ich glaube, ich habe diesen Installer, wir haben es letztes Jahr beim Windows von
Windows 9 ausprobiert, ich glaube, dieser Installer ist eines der Sachen, die ich glaube
ich öfters gesehen habe, wie das meiste andere auf dem Rechner, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das
ob das der eine oder andere noch kennt von früher, das war eine Zeit, da hat man quasi
Windows täglich bis wöchentlich, oder sag mal so, wöchentlich bis täglich neu installiert,
was ist eigentlich, wenn du den anderen fahrt als Windows, keine Ahnung, das mache ich nicht,
dann geht es wahrscheinlich nicht, oh, Nutzer definiert, Desktop, oh die Maus, Alter, was
geht mit der Maus, Desktop, japp, alle, alle Eingabe, alle Eingabenhilfe, alle Internetprogramme,
alle Multimedia, alle Online-Dienste, Outlook Express, alle Sprachunterstützung, Bulgarisch,
Polnisch, Russisch, Slowenisch, Tschechisch, Ungarisch, Weißrussisch und Türkisch brauchen
wir unbedingt, Systemprogramme, alte, alle, alle, Moment, warum kann man da nicht alles
anwählen, was ist da los, DFÜ, ATM-Unterstützung, darf man nicht hinzufügen, ok, auch gut,
warum, weil es kein Modem erkannt hat, Zubehör, alles, jawoll, ganz wichtig, wir brauchen
beim Zubehör die Windows-Spiele, sonst geht nichts, ok, eins muss man sagen, das fühlt
sich enorm responsive und schnell an, das ganze Ding, obwohl es in der, und das einzige,
also was übelst rum, was übelst rum spackt ist der Maus-Zeiger, der geht voll ab, glaube
ich sollte mal meine Maus ein bisschen niedrigere DPI einstellen, hat, hat überhaupt keinen
Unterschied, egal ob ich den DPI-Knopf drücke oder nicht, ja Pinball, genau, aber ich weiß
gar nicht, ob das standardmäßig dabei ist, dieser Pinball, diese Pinball-Geschichte,
vielleicht muss man das downloaden danach, weiter, Computername, wer war der letzte Twitch
ab, jetzt Twitch ist ab, ich gucke, das kann ich nicht aussprechen, ja, das ist halt toll,
so, wow, wow, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich mein, ich ich wollte da gar nicht drauf
sucking, ok Computername, Pogm might have Pinball on it, Pogm, Arbeitsgruppe, Werkgruppe
wunderbar, weiter, Gebiet-Schema, Deutsch, das ist ja natürlich Bend ja gut, Snow einrichten,
Papiervorgang starten, let's go
Das geht, guck mal, 60 Minuten, jetzt sind wir bei 21
Also ich hab, kann es sein, dass ich Pogu auch, sag mal, irgendwie haben sich Emotes entfernt, ne, wir hatten, wir hatten Pogu, Pogu aus Pog, hatten wir alles mal drinnen
Irgendwie die Emotes haben sich alle entfernt
Windows 98, also es geht ja so schnell, da kann ich gar nicht mehr lesen, mehr Speicherplatz, erhöhte Zuverlässigkeit
Mit zahlreichen Erweiterungen, den neuen Assistenten, erhöhte Stabilität, mehr Spaß bei der Arbeit, spannendere Spiele, Hardware-Unterstützung, alter, das ist ja fast eine Powerpoint-Slide-Show, optimierte Eingabe-Hilfen, bessere Anpassung
Windows Update, vielen Dank, easy, fertig, das war die schnellste Windows-Installation aller Zeiten, ey
Benutzernahme, Test, Schirmer lassen, weiter, akzeptiere den Vertrag, next, oh, Leute, ich muss euch kurz ausschalten, ich muss, muss mein, mein Legend-Windows-Key eingeben und ich will nicht, dass ihr den seht
Da muss ich euch kurz ausschalten, selbstverständlich, completely Legend-Windows-Key, wer hätte, wer hätte auch was anderes jetzt vermutet, ne, als, als hätte ich kein Legend-Windows-Acht-Key
Hoffentlich verschreibe ich mich jetzt nicht, weiter, jawoll, hat funktioniert, schallt euch wieder ein, Start-Assistent, fertig
Was du, man kann sich immer noch Windows-98-Keys generieren, ernsthaft, die Hardware, die nicht Plug-and-Play-kompatibel ist, wird jetzt gesucht, Achtung, dieser Vorgang kann mehrere Minuten dauern, kann vorkommen, dass der Computer nicht reagiert
Ja, oh, ich hab Angst, nicht, dass mein Computer auf einmal nicht mehr reagiert, weil ich Windows-89 installiere, starten, die, das ist auch geil, wenn die, länger ungefähr, starten sie den Computer neu, so nach dem Motto, okay, wir sind zwar Microsoft, wir haben selbst keine Ahnung mehr, was da passiert, aber starten sie einfach mal neu, dann, dann wird das schon funktionieren
ETX 1070, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich können wir noch nicht mal irgendwelche 3D-Sachen drauf starten, weil VMWare für Windows-98 keine 3D-Unterstützung hat, aber bis wir so weit kommen, direkt X zu installieren, wird eh eine Weile dauern
Wenn das hier gut funktioniert, installiere ich das auf meinem alten 4K-Xeon, jetzt neu starten
Ich hab das ewig nicht mehr gesehen, ich kriege immer noch Anfälle, wenn ich diesen Startbildschirm sehe
Ich hab das bestimmt, in der Zeit, wo das, sagen wir mal alles zusammen, 95, Windows 95 gab es ja irgendwie A, B, C, 98, 98, SE und ME, wenn man das mal zusammennimmt, komme ich bestimmt auf 100, wenn nicht mehr, neue Installationen
Ach, easy 100 neue Installationen, easy, man hat ja gefühlt jede zweite Woche oder Woche installiert, wahrscheinlich eher 200 neue Installationen oder so
3.55 Uhr, naja nicht so ganz, oder? Achso, PMAM, ja meinetwegen, meinetwegen, wenn er denkt, dass in Deutschland PMAM Uhrzeit ist, okay, kann ich mitleben, guck mal, wir haben das Jahr 19
Alles stimmt, das ist richtig, wenn alle Stricke reißen, rufe ich Peter vom indischen Microsoft Support an, die sind immerhin ein Silberpartner, kann nix schiefgehen
Bildschirmarbeitor, du hast eine Easy Money Karte, ja denn, dann generier mal Easy Money, 110 Euro, und sind sie bei dir auch schon angekommen, haben gesagt, wir spenden dich
an dieses Trommelding, da kann ich mich noch richtig gut dran erinnern, an diese komische Trommelanimation, ich hab damals immer gedacht, wenn man eine Soundkarte hätte
oder wenn man einen Audiotriver hätte, der schon während dem Setup funktioniert, würde man das Trommeln hören, gab es noch andere Leute, die diese bescheuerte Sachen gedacht haben?
Ich hab mich immer geärgert, dass ich nicht Trommeln höre im Setup, eigentlich total beknackt, aber die 60 Minuten gingen ganz schön schnell rum, oder?
Ach ja, und auch eine Sache, ich war übelst aber gläubig, was so Windows Installationen angeht, ich hab nie von Hand neu gestartet, weil ich immer gedacht hab, vielleicht startet er dann zu früh neu, wenn er noch mit was nicht fertig ist bei der Installation
Big Brain
Das ist eine VM, wenn das gut funktioniert, dann versuch ich es auf meinem alten 4k Xeon zu installieren
Doch geben sie erkennen wird für das Microsoft Netzwerk ein
Das Microsoft Netzwerk, jetzt tut er so, als ist er an irgendeiner Domäne angemeldet oder so, ist er überhaupt nicht
Neues Kennenwort, 123456, bam, unbekanntes Gerät
Standardbildschirm, oh ja, Gott sei Dank ist da Standardbildschirm dran, was hätte er denn nur die ganze Zeit anzeigen sollen, wenn er den Standardbildschirm nicht erkannt hätte?
So, huge 16 Farben, Wahnsinn
Die beste Animation aller Zeiten
Gehen wir fort
Sieht schon mal ganz toll aus
Active Desktop
Jetzt aktuell also das hat sich das hat sich gebackt geht schon mal nicht weg so ganz wichtig das erste was wir machen müssen Internet Explorer
Ach so Moment wir müssen ja vorher erst noch die Verbindung mit dem Internet
Weiter
Weiter weiter
Alter ich will kein Modem, ich will mein Netzwerk verwenden
Modem, wenn wir mich verarschen
Netzwerk ist verbunden, hat er denn die Netzwerkkarte erkannt?
Okay Leute wisst ihr das erste was wir machen ist wir installieren jetzt erstmal VMA Tools
Der DFU Adapter
So wo steht Netzwerkkarte?
Internetverbindungspreis
AMD Ethernet Adapter, doch das ist der richtige
Netzwerk Umgebung wie Eigenschaften, ah ja hier
IP da TCP IP
IP automatisch beziehen
So und wie ging das jetzt unter Windows?
CMD, was?
CMD Exe
Alter wie macht man unter Windows den Terminal auf?
Terminal 98
Zubehör
Wie macht man unter Windows 98 den Terminal auf?
Daten an CMD habe ich ja gerade gemacht, geht nicht
Wie geht denn das?
Das muss doch funktionieren
Command?
Ah
Wir haben doch eine IP
So alles gut sollte doch eigentlich auch funktionieren Internet Explorer
Bam
Ich will kein Modem installieren
Alter ich will, ich will kein Modem
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack
Windows will das ja
Ok ich habe eine Idee wir machen jetzt Trick 17
Wir entfernen das einfach alles
So
Jawoll
Wir entfernen das einfach alles und dann geht es bestimmt
An Windows 98 Raytracing Support, oh das wäre so, also mein sogar Excel hat Raytracing
Ach Startbildschirme
Mein Gott was, Microsoft was willst du von mir
Ist das denen nicht in den Sinn gekommen, der Computer muss neu gestartet werden
Ist das denen nicht in den Sinn gekommen, dass man vielleicht ins Internet will ohne ein Modem
Hier Windows Setup wir entfernen das jetzt einfach alles Internet Programme
Wo konnte man den ganzen Mist, hier Online Dienste, zack alles weg
Aul CompuSurf
Verbindung alles weg
Alles, alles weg
So
Übernehmen
Neustarten
Ruf Peter an ja
Die Netzwerkkarte hat ja einen Treiber, aber Windows checkt es irgendwie nicht
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Achtung jetzt
Das geht mir mega oft, was ist das denn
Ok ich starte neu
Windows ey, das ist ja noch schlimmer als das
Das ist mega schnell das Neustarten
Wir inszenieren jetzt erstmal vor Amber Tools
Kann ich hier sowas machen
Jibay das funktioniert nicht
Ok Google
Windows 98 without Modem MSN
Aha siehste schon der erste Eintrag
Google Panel and find Internet Options
Go to Connections Tab and click Setup
Da muss man erstmal drauf kommen
System
Internet
Verbindung
Setup
Aha 900i big brainer
Internetverbindung manuell einrichten oder über ein lokales Netzwerk
Automatische Suche
Nein kein E-Mail Konto weiter
Ok Internetverbindung herstellen sehr gut
Alter was ist das denn
Aber es funktioniert
Ok Google
Ok ich mein es funktioniert Achtung YouTube
HTTPS geht natürlich geht HTTPS nicht
HTTPS kann nicht funktionieren weil das garantiert kein neueres TLS kann
YouTube
Jawoll
YouTube.com
Ok geht nicht
Alter der will mich zu HTTPS umleihen das geht nicht
Ok wir inszenieren jetzt erstmal vor Amber Tools
Dass wir eine ordentliche Auflösung und Farbe kriegen
Ich kann nicht auf mein eigenes Stream gehen Twitch geht bestimmt auch nicht
Twitch TV wo blorst
Nee der will auf HTTPS umleihen das
Klippfisch gibt es das überhaupt noch
Ok ok also erstmal vor Amber Tools installieren
Install vor Amber Tools
Wir installieren uns jetzt einen neuen Firefox oder sowas einen neueren Firefox
Click install to connect ja ja yes
Installieren wir jetzt erstmal vor Amber Tools
Max ich hatte heute ein Vorstellungsgespräch für eine DevOps Engineer Stelle
Während dem Gespräch gingen bei mir wieder alle Alarmglocken an
Vertrauensarbeitszeit wir machen keine Überstunden
Vertrauensarbeitszeit ist erstmal heißt ja im Endeffekt du musst nicht du musst
Es kann gut oder schlecht sein ich mein du machst halt keine Zeiterfassung
Und weil ich mir gar nicht so sicher bin wie das rechtlich mittlerweile ist ob das ohne Zeiterfassung überhaupt noch geht
24 Tage Urlaub das ist aber ganz schön wenig ich glaube 24 Tage Urlaub ist das gesetzliche was man mindestens geben muss
15 Jahre altes Java, IGIT
Java
Außerdem wollen die mir die Vermögenswirksam Leistung kostenlose Getränke als geiles Feature verkaufen
Vermögenswirksam Leistung weiß ich nicht wie weit das gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist aber
Die 20 Euro also kostenlose Getränke und Obst
Ja gut also wenn das das einzig geile Feature ist was die haben dann weiß ich auch nicht
Das ist immer schwierig zu sagen das ist ziemlich nur nach 15 es ist aber einfach so das ist
Viele Läden nicht schaffen sich sich ordentlich selbst darzustellen als dass sie toll sind
Aber 24 Tage ist schon ist schon ganz schön wenig
Also ich mein das ist okay wenn die halt richtig nice money bezahlen ja
Okay, wie ist denn die Bezahlung also wenn die Bezahlung gut ist warum nicht
Weiter install
Oh huge Maustreiber jawoll jetzt ist die Maus vielleicht ein bisschen flüssiger gleich
Er hat schon lieber abonniert auf stufe 8 Abonnent gewechselt Abo gewechselt POG
Samus Kleimer
Yes fertig neustart was
Eine Auswurf Anforderung Ach wie geil die Windows Übersetzung damals gewesen sind oder
Eine Auswurf Anforderung wurde für ein aktives Laufwerk empfangen soll der Datenträger
Ausgeworfen werden
Ja
Fertig Neustart Yes
Die Windows Übersetzung war einfach die besten
Bildschirmarbeiter wie ist denn die Bezahlung haben die sich dazu geäußert
Das Neustarten geht halt so krass schnell
Oh wir haben Farben Leute wir haben Farben seht ihr das wir haben 32 Bit Farbtiefe
Poggers
Es sieht gleich gar nicht mehr so scheiße aus und wir haben 800 mal 600 Auflösung
Jetzt passt mal auf vielleicht haben wir sogar Full HD Auflösung
Vielleicht haben wir sogar
Bäm
Wir haben Full HD Auflösung 32 Bit Farbtiefe und der Windows 98
1080p
Easy
Die Icons sind halt huge ne
Ok Symbol anordnen automatisch zack der Aktenkoffer
Das ist ein Feature von Windows weil ich nie gecheckt habe wozu man das überhaupt braucht
Der Aktenkoffer
So und jetzt das allerwichtigste wir müssen
Blaue Noppen brauchen wir ganz wichtig
Poster
Haben wir nicht 20 Desktop Themes mit installiert
Bildschirmschoner
Labyrinth oh jawoll
Huge Graphics
Rohre
Kann sich an den Crab noch jemand erinnern
Ja das war nice
Baseball
Das war es für die Amis das ist das ist das ist so richtig so richtig Kokona
Ich erkenne übrigens nichts
Passiert da noch was
Das ist das ist richtig Kokona Bildschirmschoner
Oh ja das war nice
Der allerbeste Bildschirmschoner war was ist das denn gewesen
Geht nicht der allerbeste Bildschirmschoner immer noch Star
Wie ist das Sterne
Das da das war der beste Bildschirmschoner
Den hatte ich damals immer
Hat mich übelst gefeiert
Anzahl der Sterne 200 oh je oh je oh je
Man kann übrigens hier nichts eintippen geht bloß hoch
Ja ja 24 Monat sind gesetzlich vorgeschrieben drunter geht nicht
Gibt es das Neues zu 5 ja fertig
Einer hat was geliefert
Der Rest hatte keinen Bock
Big Plane Bildschirmschoner
Man sieht sogar dass die Sterne viereckig sind anstatt
Anstatt
Rund
Richtig richtig 3D
Bildschirmschoner mal wieder aus nicht dass der jetzt auf einmal noch zwischendurch angeht
Energiesparfunktion
Oh der Bildschirmarbeiter hat geantwortet
24 Tage Urlaub sind glaube ich genauso wie vermögenswirksame Leistungen vorgeschrieben
Ja ja also 24 Monate auf jeden Fall
Vermögenswirksame Leistungen weiß ich nicht genau aber
24 Tage Urlaub ist glaube ich das mindeste was gesetzlich erlaubt ist
Also mindestens sein muss so viel
Bezüglich der Vertrauensarbeitszeit kann ich aus meinen Erfahrungen sagen
Dass es in den meisten Fällen dazu führt dass die Leute mehr arbeiten als sie eigentlich müssen
Ja das ist natürlich kacke
Bei uns ist es ein bisschen anders
Bei uns wird eigentlich die Zeit ganz normal erfasst
Allerdings hatten Leute die früher viele Überstunden gemacht haben
So quasi so ein Vertrauensarbeitszeit Modell
Dass es nicht so auffällt quasi
Und die haben halt pauschal einen Betrag mehr gekriegt
Und das war ganz ordentlich
Leute ist so dass keiner mal richtig Überstunden machen darf
Und die Vertrauensarbeitsleute allerdings immer noch mehr Geld kriegen
Weil sie einen besseren Vertrag haben
Also bei uns ist das nicht verkehrt
Ja Arbeitszeiten müssen erfasst werden
Das habe ich auch letztens gelesen
24 Tage nicht 24 Monate
Schema Windows Standard Rosen
Ok ich glaube
Das sieht einfach alles kacke aus wir lassen das jetzt
Aber wir brauchen schon wir brauchen schon irgendwie
Ägypten
Sah das alles kacke aus damals
Hanentritt
Alter da kriegst du ja epileptische Anfälle von
Kreise
Alter da kriegst du ja Anfälle von
Boah das tut ja weh
Der ausgewählte Hintergrund kann nur bei aktiviertem Active Desktop angezeigt werden
Lieber nicht
Ich weiß nicht was es tut aber
Oh ja das war das das das das hatte man damals
Der Wolkenhintergrund
Das hat man damals ja genau der Wolkenhintergrund
Der muss sein
Der sieht auf 1080p gestreckt nicht mehr ganz so gut aus
Der sieht auf 1080p ein bisschen ein bisschen sehr pixelig aus
Du arbeitest doch in Frankfurt ja
Woher hast du das Image
Achieve.org
Hallo Drogo Leon
Die Cloud das ist die originale Cloud genau
Was haben wir denn zu bieten Online Dienste nichts
Info über Online Dienste können wir uns AOL installieren
Ok wie es hier ausslide
Ok als nächstes Sound installieren Leute Soundtreiber brauchen wir
Die Sache ist bloß die ich habe keine Ahnung welchen Soundtreiber wir installieren müssen
Warum weiß ich eigentlich noch dass man so in Geräte Manager kommt
Das war voll automatisch dass ich gerade gesagt habe zack Geräte Manager
Das habe ich mir irgendwie gemerkt
So also PCI Multimedia Audio Device
Das könnte die Soundkarte sein
Sind Spiele drauf installiert
Ja wir haben alles installiert was sind halt Spiele drauf
Freestyle, Hearts, Minesweeper
Wenn du schon direkt beim Vorstellungsgespräch ein schlechtes Gefühl hast
Würde ich da gar nicht hin
Pinball ist anscheinend nicht drauf können wir gleich suchen
Aber dazu brauchen wir erstmal ein bisschen moderneren Browser
Und das allerwichtigste ist wir brauchen Sound
Also eins davon wird die Soundkarte sein
Und Windows 98 for Mware
Hier ist all for what I use in Windows 98 Virtual Machine
Creative Com in Soundblaster Treiber easy der wird jetzt installiert
Downloaden Soundblaster Treiber
Die Datei auf dem Datenträger speichern
Guck mal wir haben 32 Farbtiefe und übelst nice Auflösungen
Da kann man sich nur wirklich nicht drüber beschweren
Rüchte es mal an
Die haben 1920x1000
Ok also weiter
Soundblaster Treiber installieren
Mal ob das jetzt funktioniert
Alle Ports für die VM Erfler und Internet Explorer ein bisschen surfen
Ja ganz genau
Wie hast du das denn geschafft was denn
Ok ja
Windows Treiber werden aktualisiert
PCI Multimedia Audio Device da ist es
Zack
SB PCI WDM
Jetzt wird hier Treiber
32 mit Farbtiefe und auflösungen
Ganz einfach ich habe VM Ertools installiert
Die machen das für mich
Ich muss mal die Taskleiste ein Ticken größer machen geht das überhaupt
Wirklich
Schriftgröße
Konnte man die Schriftgröße unter Windows größer machen
Weißt du das jemand konnte man die Schriftgröße größer machen
Eingabe, Hilfen
Front
Schriftarten
System
Sound
Ich will grad nicht erst aufhören wir haben Sound
Poggers wir haben Sound Leute
Treiber installiert zwar immer noch aber wir haben Sound
Lautstärke
Guck mal hier wir haben sogar noch den primitiven Windows Mixer am Start
Kann man irgendwie die Schriftgröße ändern
Windows 98 Font Size
Font Size ok wie kann man die Font Size ändern
Nein Computer wird später neu gestartet Eigenschaften
Einstellungen
Weitere Optionen
Ah hier
Kleine Schrift an große Schrift an
Hast du jetzt was getan
200% Schriftdaten
Ok na dann nicht
Große Schriftdaten
Achso stimmt ganz vergessen man muss ja damals jeden Mist neu starten
Ja das ist das ist gut
Tarifvertrag ist generell nicht schlecht finde ich
Wenn da irgendwelche Läden drin sind
Kriegste automatisch alle eins zwei Jahre immer ein bisschen mehr
Weil nicht das ist jetzt die Rede wert wäre wahnsinnig viel doch guck mal die Schriftgröße ist angepasst
High DPI Settings für Windows 98
Was passiert hier Windows 98 passiert
Nee Fiverr ist fertig ich habe ein Ergebnis habe ich vom indischen Programmierer
Also 10 von 11 haben haben gecancelt
Oh ist es jetzt kaputt
Ich hätte einen Snapshot machen sollen
Alter
Der Sound
Mit der E-Gitarre
Alter
Ok wir blenden den Bildschirm aus
Was nervt das nämlich jedes mal schließen
Wo ist mein audio
Wo ist mein audio backen
Ich kann die lautstärke nicht mehr ändern mein audio button ist weg
Eben war der audio button noch da
Multimedia
Ich kann die lautstärke nicht ändern mehr
Weg
Wie kommt man in dieses Mixer Menü rein
Hardware Beschleunigung keine 100%
Ok man kann 50% Hardware beschleunigen oder was
Aber egal wir haben Sound das passt schon
Kann ich mit leben
Ok also jetzt wird es schwierig
Jetzt müssen wir halbwegs versuchen wir mal halbwegs
Clippy nie Clippy war Clippy war nein Clippy ist Office
Ich bin aus XP Clippy ist Office
So
E1 muss ich sagen das fühlt sich wahnsinnig schnell an
Das fühlt sich extrem schnell an alles
Drucker auf machen ist nicht so
Dieser Klick Sound
Die Oberfläche fühlt sich extrem schnell an
Wenn ich Multimedia einstelle war man ja gerade schon
Ist irgendwie nichts
Ach da
Warum ist das aus auf einmal
Warum ist das auf einmal aus das war doch eben noch an
Gut ok als nächstes
Ein halbwegs aktuellen Browser brauchen wir jetzt
Was ist der letzte Firefox der auf Windows 98
Läuft
Firefox 37 37 kann doch im Leben nicht auf 98 laufen oder
Das der letzte der auf XP läuft vielleicht aber
Ja 98 ist da nicht mal dabei
XP XP
Wir brauchen aber 98
Last Firefox Windows 98
What is the latest version of Firefox
That will run on Windows 98
Was das
Firefox 10
Moment das ist irgendwas anderes
Was zum Teufel ist
Colonel Ex
Colonel Ex 457
Was ist das
About
Colonel Ex
Das müssen wir ausprobieren
Opera 9.6.4
Opera ist eine gute Idee das das probieren wir mal aus
Gibt es das irgendwie aus einer halbwegs vertrauenswürdigen Quelle zum Download
Ich meine was sind das alles was sind das alles für Download Quellen
Was zum Teufel das lade ich mir doch nicht
Das lade ich mir doch nicht runter
Firefox 2002 ok
Können wir gleich mal ausprobieren
2.0
Ja das da
Das letzte 2.0 Release das ergibt auch irgendwie Sinn
Deutsche Version wenn schon klar
Ok Download
Und jetzt zum Glück haben wir es in einer VM laufen
Weil jetzt kann ich einfach auf Download gehen
Und mir den Gramm rüber kopieren easy
Weiter akzept wir akzeptieren alles weiter standard
Firefox starten
Nichts importieren
Firefox am Start
Hol dir die neueste Firefox Version
Ich glaube das ist keine so gute Idee
Ok YouTube Punkt
Ich meine das kann nicht gehen das kann garantiert kein HTW5 Video
Aber die Seite geht schon mal auf immerhin
Die Seite startet schon mal
Was war das jetzt
Nein danke
Es sieht aus nach YouTube
Funny Animal Vines na gut das Video wird nicht funktionieren
So Achtung
Seite aber er kennt was es ist und es läuft soll ich euch mal was sagen es läuft
Verhältnismäßig schnell
Oh ranzoom geht natürlich nicht gescheit
Ranzoom ist fail
Kann man seinen Zoom resetten
Hier kann man wenigstens können ich wenigstens Kommentare lesen
Ne brauche mittlerweile brauche ja alles Javascript auf YouTube da geht ja nichts
Flash
Ich glaube nicht dass ich noch einen Flash Player finde der Windows 98 unterstützt
Aber das funktioniert schon mal schon mal cool
Ok dann probieren wir mal diese Colonel E-X Geschichte aus
Colonel E-X
Download
Schau mal hier
Ach das sind irgendwelche Packs von von sagen wir mal Fans
Aber das ist gut für Codex und solche Zeugte speichere ich mir mal die Seite
Ok Download
Das kann man hier nicht runterladen ne
Man muss das hier runterladen
Das unterstützt hat halt alles HTTPS was ja auch gut ist aber Windows 98 kann halt keine HTTPS
Zumindest doch Firefox der kann schon HTTPS der hat aber halt wahrscheinlich TLS 1 oder sowas
Download Latest Version
Download
Shortly
Und habe ich vielleicht irgendwas geplockt
Die meisten Viewer sind wahrscheinlich jünger als Windows 98 und die Musik ist aus
Dann lauben wir das halt
Accept
Jetzt download auch
Ok zack
Da mal zu kopieren es rüber damit können wir jetzt neuere Sachen ausführen oder was
Erstmal installieren erstmal erstmal alles aus dem Internet downloaden und installieren
So wie man das unter Windows 98
Was Microsoft layer for Unicode is required
Would you like to con- No
Was zum Teufel ist der Microsoft Unicode layer
Da blickste ne mal durch hier
Download
If Unicode layer
Da
Download
So hat man das unter Windows schön ge- Das war immer nice
Einfach alles runterladen und sinnlos installieren so muss das sein
Unicodes
Cows
Yes
Extract
Auf Desktop
Fuck
Was ist das
Das License Agreement
Was mach ich damit jetzt nach System 32 kopieren oder so
Das ist so fail
System 32
Oh da ist ja gar nichts drin
Die Drohnen für Twitch bleiben Dankeschön
Wir kopieren das jetzt nach
Windows
System
Weiß man nicht was ich da kopiere
Aber ich kopiere es einfach dahin
Jetzt installieren wir das nochmal
Enable kernel extensions
Reboot
Jawoll immer rebooten
Das war das allerwichtigste bei Windows 98
Hauptsache dauerhaft rebooten
Flashplayer 9
Was wo hast du
Ach
Ach man kann sich den alten Flashplayer runterladen oder was
Oh nice
Den downloaden wir jetzt den alten Flashplayer
Und da gucken wir uns YouTube an
Kokona
Ich meine ohne scheiß Leute wenn man das so sieht
Es sieht gar nicht auf den ersten Blick aus wie Windows 98 oder
Es sieht so mit dem Firefox im Vollbild
Es sieht neuer aus
Auch weil die Seiten halbwegs ok aussehen
Ok Flashplayer
Flashplayer
Download
Gibt es gar nicht mehr
Gibt kein Flashplayer 9 mehr
Doch
253 MB war das
Oh Mist
Wie mache ich denn jetzt einen ZIP auf
Hatte schon so was eingebaut gehabt
Fuck
7 ZIP Windows 98
Die Seite geht natürlich
Alte Version von Windows 7
Ok
GIF
Ok ja
Download
Das war noch Zeiten von Windows da hast du jeden Scheiß aus dem Internet runtergeladen
In der Hoffnung das ist kein Virus am Start
Download ist kaputt
Winra genau
Windows 98 SE Utilities
Oh die Seite sieht schon mal huge vertrauenserweckend aus
7 ZIP Download
Spreiche mal
Tweak Utility Windows Media Player
Process Explorer
Oh ja
Den brauchen wir
Den Process Explorer
Richtig
Wer weiß was wir jetzt für die ganzen Viren runterladen
Gut aber was soll passieren das Ding ist in der VM
Ok
7 ZIP
Install
Seht ihr mal wie schnell der Scheiß installiert ist im Vergleich zu heute
7 ZIP
Da ist es
Wahnsinn
Process Explorer
So erstmal hier
Entpacken
Jawoll
Was war das hier noch mal
Flash
Player
Und hier noch der Process Explorer
Boah BÄM
Da ist er
Wahnsinnig viel was hier läuft
Das ist die übelste Hardware ja klar
Aber trotzdem ich finde es nice wie mega schnell das sich anfühlt im Vergleich zu Windows 10
Windows 10 fühlt sich schon relativ schnell an
Kann man das minimieren irgendwie in Task Club
Jetzt gesehen in der Taskleiste ist es jetzt
View
Aber es ist weg wenn man es schließt
Egal wir lassen es jetzt so
Perfekt
Also den Mist den können wir alles löschen
Quatsch
Komm wir müllen uns schön den Desktop zu das ist doch eigentlich viel besser
Eigene Dateien aufwärts Moment wo sind Downloads
Eigene Dateien
Ne
Moment wo ist mein Download Ordner
Ich glaube mein Desktop ist mein Download Ordner
Ach da ist es schon ey
Ok Flash Player installieren
Linux
Was davon installiert man jetzt
Was da
Installation fertig
Wie das war es schon
ActiveX
Ah das ist eine Firefox das andere ist Internet Explorer
Ok
Addons
Ich sehe da kein Flash Player
Kein Flash Player da
Ta
App
Reboot
Meint ihr man kann ja nicht für jeden Crap Rebooten
Aber es ist gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich dass wir Rebooten müssen
Aber guck mal wie schnell das Rebooted
Danach müssen wir noch E-Mails abrufen
Guck ob das funktioniert
Ich weiss nicht wie es sogar die geschlossenen Fenster wieder herstellt
Huge Features
Alter nerv nicht
Addons
Ne kein Flash Player
Aber mal gucken vielleicht geht ja YouTube trotzdem
YouTube
Nö
Gibt es nicht
Ist Flash nicht ein Plugin
Gute Frage
Aber ich weiß noch nicht mal wo man das hier sieht
Plugins
Gibt es hier gar nicht an der Stelle
Oh Max Max das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee
Ich wollte gerade sagen ich habe auch gar keine Ahnung ob überhaupt noch YouTube funktioniert mit mit Flash
Gut
Aber das ist ja schon mal was hier
Wir sehen jetzt mal eine neuere eine neuere Firefox Version aus
Mit diesem Kernel X
Ding
Firefox
Moment wie hat man noch mal was deinstalliert Software
Active
YouTube
Ach Quatsch die ging ja nicht
Ok dann
Deinstallieren wir mal wieder vielleicht Flash Player
Und deinstallieren Firefox
Nein oder
Doch
Deinstallieren Firefox
Und dann gucken wir uns hier an
Kernel X
Firefox
Was war das neueste was man unter Windows 98 damit installieren kann
Da ist er
Chip
Download
Firefox
Let's go
Das Chip gebadet ein übrigens
Wenn ihr euch das hier jetzt runter lädt
Lädt ihr so einen komischen Chip Installer runter den keiner haben will
Man muss auf manuelle Installationen gehen unter Download
Sogar Chip gebadet ein schon
Das Desktop ist weg
Das Ding hat einfach meinen Desktop gelöscht
Neustarten
Reboot immer Reboot natürlich Reboot was sonst
Was meint ihr denn
Ich bin dumm Leute ich bin richtig hängen geblieben ich habe keinen Snapshot gemacht
Ach nee geht wieder
Ok easy
Hauptsache mein Desktop gelöscht
Ich mach jetzt einfach mal einen Snapshot
Ups
Ok passt
Und jetzt wollte ich den neuen Firefox hier drauf kopieren
Download
Firefox
Da ist er
Settingschaften
Compatibility Mode
Zack
Aha jetzt funktioniert es
Und schon haben wir noch einen neueren Firefox
Youtube.com
Das sieht schon noch ein bisschen besser aus oder
Das sieht noch ein bisschen originaler aus jetzt
Guck mal sogar der Ladebalken geht schon
Sogar der Ladebalken geht schon
Ok was stand was ist die neueste Version die geht
Firefox 10.0.12 esr
Das probieren wir jetzt auch noch aus
Wir tasten uns ran bald haben wir Chrome 75 drauf
Ah nee de
Ich war mittlerweile gehen ja Downloads und so schon immerhin ohne Probleme
Wo hat er das Setup jetzt
Wo ist es ich blick nicht mehr durch auf meinem Desktop nach Datum
Wo hat es denn jetzt da gelaudet
Wo ist es denn jetzt
Ach jetzt haben wir auf einmal einen Download Ordner oder was
Das ist echt Microsoft Logik
Software
Deinstallieren Firefox
Ok jetzt ist Firefox 10
Huge Versionssprung
Wo ist es
Installieren
Was mit der Schrift los
Youtube.com Slash Max Yes die Schrift ist kaputt
Die Schrift ist im Arsch
Aha
Er kann aber schon mehr kann er Comments anzeigen
Die Kommentare sind da
Die Kommentare sind am Start
Und er will aus 98 YouTube YouTube und er will aus 98 das sieht fast aus wie YouTube
Nur dass die Videos nicht gehen
Ok wo gab es die Flash Flash Geschichten zum Download
Wir gucken jetzt was die letzte Windows XP Version ist
Und die installieren wir weil wir haben jetzt irgendwie die Möglichkeit XP Sachen laufen zu lassen
Die da nehmen wir letzte Windows 2000 Version
Hier den will ich haben
Dann brauchen wir noch voll C
FDP
Full C Last Version Windows 98
Ich meine guck mal wir können
Wir können Browsen ganz normal
Wir können ganz normal unter Windows 98 Browsen mittlerweile schon
Ist das nicht nice
Ich meine ok vielleicht sollten wir NoScript installieren
Ich glaube wir installieren mal NoScript
Man weiß ja nie so genau was man sich einfängt
Lulwe
Wo haben die wo haben die die alten Versionen
Klar NoScript geht NoScript hat eine Version hat eine
Was haben wir denn latest NoScript 1.9 bis 12
Ich weiß nur dass die Gecko Version nicht unbedingt mit Firefox Version übereinstimmen
Aber ich probiere mal den hier
Erlauben
NoScript ist installiert
Easy
Wo ist NoScript
NoScript ist immer unten eigentlich gewesen
Da ist es NoScript
Wir haben einen halbwegs aktuellen Firefox von 2011 oder so
Mit NoScript am Start
Ok und jetzt noch den Flash Player Alter jetzt noch den Flash Player
Dann gucken wir YouTube Videos und da Windows 98
Flash Player
Ne wo ist er da
Wir haben sogar einen 7-Zip zum Zips entpacken
Netflix Entschild
Wartet mal Netflix
Die Schrift ist ein bisschen kaputt
Ja
Ich meine es sieht aus wie Netflix
Warte mal welche
Clipfisch gibt es das noch
Aber Vimeo oder wie das heißt gibt es bestimmt noch
Ah fuck die hat eine zu neue SSL Version
Ok Videos
Ah Mist man kann es nicht aufmachen
Aber Flash Player
34 Bit 32 Bit brauchen wir
Flash Player 32 Bit
Was ist denn der Unterschied
Das ist Active X
Wir wollen ja kein Active X
Wir wollen ja normales haben Flash Player install
Ist das jetzt installiert Addons
Shockwave Flash Alter Leute wir haben Flash Player installiert
Also wenn jetzt YouTube geht rast ich aus
Man Firefox Jubelser abspacken
Ja ja wir erlauben alles ist gut
Oh kacke Man Firefox
Ich glaube man Firefox ist gecrasht
Oh no
Ok ich muss mal nach dem Video von mir suchen
Klage hieß doch das letzte
Wir erlauben alles
Ok wir akzeptieren die YouTube Nutzungsbedingungen
Wir erlauben alles ist gut YouTube alles
Ich erlaub alles
Konnte man nicht NoScript temporär irgendwie abschalten
Temporär
Skript allgemein erlauben ok
Oder ging das nicht temporär
YouTube bietet kein Flash mehr an
YouTube hat kein Flash mehr
Vielleicht ein altes Video von mir
Vielleicht ein altes Video wo sie es noch haben
Inzugefügt älteste zuerst
Ok erstes Video von mir
Alter ist der Browser langsam jetzt
Wer ist halt voll überfordert mit halbwegs aktuellem Java
Och nee
Leute wir können kein YouTube gucken
Und der Windows 98 geht nicht mehr
Geh auf den Link
Ja da komme ich immer schief von meinem Kanal raus
Aber die Videos werden auch da nicht drin sein oder
Kannst du nicht Video in den VLC packen doch
Allerdings habe ich auch kein aktuellen VLC
Vielleicht hat er ein Video gespeichert von mir
Komm hab ein Video von mir
Nee ne
Hat er nicht
Mein Maus ist kaputt
Kann ich mal scrollen mit der Maus
So sah mein Channel damals aus
Krass zum YouTube Designs
Gibt es den mehr
Über Flash Player
Leider hat das keine Videos von mir archiviert anscheinend
Oder verstehe ich ja irgendwo auch
Wobei das ist zu neu
Nee Twitch läuft nicht
Weil Twitch braucht neuere HTTPS Variante
Die hat die hat es nicht
Ja Twitch TV
Vielleicht Mobile
Mobile Twitch
Gibt es da irgendwie noch die Variante Twitch ohne HTTPS aufzumachen
Nee wird nicht mehr funktionieren
Ja es gibt kaum noch Seiten ohne HTTPS was ja eigentlich auch ganz gut ist
Nee
Die Videos hat er nicht gespeichert
Keine Chance
Kennt ihr mal eine Video Seite
Ist keine Porn oder so
Die
Die keiner HTTPS braucht
Oh mein Browser ist abgestürzt
Hip
Firefox kaputt
Das ganze Betriebssystem hängt
Das ganze Betriebssystem hängt weil Firefox abgestürzt ist
Okay
Task Manager
Aber ich wette mit euch wir müssen wir müssen neu starten
Reagiert nicht
Task beenden
Hey
Windows 98 ist nicht abgestürzt
Wenn Twitch Streams funktionieren die Embedded wurden
Das kann sein wenn das kein HTTPS ist hast du mal link zum Embedded
Embedded Stream für
My Video
Gibt es das noch
Oder was war das nochmal My Video
Nee gibt es nicht mehr
Wie Meo gibt es noch
Daily Motion haben wir noch zu bieten
Daily Motion gab es noch
Reddit
Reddit können wir ausprobieren
Daily Motion haben wir noch
Was Offline Modus
Nein
Tagesschau
Stimmt die haben sowas alles bestimmt noch
Es lädt
Ich will nicht dass es lädt
Aber das können wir mit dem VLC jetzt jetzt abspielen
Das ist auch HTTPS
Daily Motion was macht Daily Motion so
Witli
Ok Reddit
Reddit
PC Master Race
Ja Reddit funktioniert
Ich meine das neue Reddit ist für einen Arsch wir müssen
Wir müssen Old Reddit machen
Old Reddit sieht ok aus
Kann man sich nicht beschweren
Ich meine es ist Windows 98
Das wollen wir
SSD Joke
Die Seite alter die Seite kack
Firefox kack die ganze Zeit ab
Das ist zu viel JavaScript für den armen Firefox 10
Das ist zu viel JavaScript das macht da nicht mit
Aber immerhin stürzt nicht der ganze Rechner ab
Ok Tagesschau hatten wir
Download der Videodatei klein mittel groß
HD
Na ja wenn schon wenn schon volle Pulle oder
Wenn schon volle Pulle downloaden
Ja wir haben kein Videoplayer ok
Wir müssen jetzt gucken was der letzte VLC ist
Windows 98 was ist der letzte VLC der unter 98
ZDF
Livestream
Ob das war ein Back
Das sieht ziemlich kaputt aus ehrlich gesagt
Das macht nichts mehr hier
Das funktioniert nicht Bahn die Bahn die geht wahrscheinlich
Zu neue SSL Version
Ok es ist echt schwierig
Wir installieren jetzt
VLC 111
Last Version
Was ist eine alte VLC Version die unter Windows 98 läuft
Komm wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal eine alte Version
Was ist denn die letzte 1er Version
ZDF
Ok jetzt probieren wir erstmal ob ich mal ein Video abspielen kann
Das war ja eines der Sachen die ich ausprobieren wollte
Das letzte Gameplay was ich im Video hatte wollte ich ausprobieren
Unter Windows 98 können wir die Taskleiste vergrößern ja
Du kannst die hier bis bis da ganz schön weit rauf ziehen
Sollen wir mal gucken ob wir die Schriftgröße
Resetten ne ich glaube die Schriftgröße immer noch
Ich hab mich nur dran gewöhnt
Sonste machen
Grip
Taskleiste abgestürzt
Power off
Ich will das gar nicht speichern
Nicht dass ich jetzt die ganze Zeit diese fette
Diese fette äh Leiste hab
Oh scanlist Gesamtstart
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das Laufwerk kaputt gemacht
Oh MonkaS es hängt
Es hängt
Und jetzt
Beenden
Weiter
Okay geht
Einfach beenden
Was ist denn bei Microsoft Logik alter
Ok
Das ist das mp2 also wohlgemerkt das video ist 720p sehen jahre nach bin aus 98
Das funst moment es hängt oder
Ne es bewegt sich
Leute wir gucken gerade
Wir gucken gerade ernsthaft
Ich hätte nicht mit gerechnet ob der auf 4k packt siehst du nicht wie pixelig das ist
der hat schon problem mit 720p
Wir müssen jetzt noch
Okay das funktioniert schon mal ich bin ich bin begeistert vielleicht geht jetzt mit dem
vlc plugin auch die tageschau
Vlc plugin vielleicht geht jetzt auch die tageschau
Wir deinstallieren glaube ich den flash player mal wieder
Ah ging etwas schief
Der hohe quali vlc nicht in full hd in 720p ich mein das ist doch schon mal was oder der
flash player jetzt nicht da irgendwie rein reinspielt und rumspackt
Flashplayer abversion 10.2 haben wir doch gehabt haben wir doch gehabt
Warum gebadet mich die tageschau seite
Warum werde ich da gebadet
Und jetzt sagt er fehler wenn ich drauf gehe wahrscheinlich
Ja super geil
Wir gehen auf youtube okay wir haben keine historie
Ich habe 10.1 nein ich habe 11.1
Geht doch nix
Oh ne fuck Video direkt aufmachen anders da geht das nicht
Hm kann man das im vlc selber abspielen
Oh oh nein nein kann man nicht
4k ich hab ich hab kein 4k video
4k demo video
4kmedia.org klingt ja schon mal toll
60 fps 4k auf gehts
Wo kann man das downloaden
Gar nicht das ist ne skmars seite vielleicht habe ich jetzt zig viren unter windows drauf
Hier zum beispiel uhd 3d demo
Oh ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne geh fort ich weiß nicht was das
worauf ich da jetzt rausgekommen bin aber irgendwo ich ich schalte mal ich schalte mal
no script wieder ein
Jawoll so erst mal no script wieder einschalten
Und ganz wichtig proces explorer aufmachen um zu gucken ob im hintergrund irgendwie schon
die schon die viren am start sind unter windows 98 man weiß ja nie so genau
Ja die bunny demo genau big bunny 4k irgendwie 4k
4k sender genau
4k quad full hd 60 fps bam jawoll
Das geht ihm leben nicht
Ja gucken wir mal ob unser host schon infiziert ist
Moment ich glaube euch hat es gerade wieder rausgehauen
Oh ist unser host schon infiziert von der vm mit viren
Einen sieht nicht so aus
Aber seht ihr mal den unterschied was hier bei windows 10 im hintergrund läuft
Vergleich zu dem was bei windows 98 läuft
Was ist denn msvmon ah der virtual studio debugger
Ich meine es ist schon ein riesen unterschied oder
Guckt euch den proces explorer da an und guckt euch den proces explorer da an
Ist schon ein bisschen ein unterschied was da im hintergrund läuft oder
Oh rip oje oje firefox ist firefox ist rip
Hab ich überhaupt genug festplattenplatz
Ja oje firefox firefox rip
Das war aber normal unter windows 98 ne
Also es ist jetzt nicht so dass es an der vm liegt
Die software unter windows 98 war halt genauso scheiße wie man hier sieht
Downloads fängt ja wieder von vorn an
Ok wir machen den ganzen kram mal aus
Es muss doch irgendwas geben was ich hier im browser abspielen kann
Mit mit plugin die mio irgendeine andere kacke video seite
Ach ne die geht schon mal gar nicht
Ok keine ahnung keine chance mehr
Im installer haben sie uns erzählen windows 98 ist das beste windows das es je gab
Ist der flash player zu neu für den firefox ne
Der flash player ist die seiten haben alle kein flash mehr im angebot beziehungsweise
Äh brauchen wahrscheinlich einen neueren oder kacken ab oder was weiß ich
Max hast du auch schon deine hinterachsen verstärken lassen
Du meinst dass ich die gehälter äh dass ich die die horne rare fahren kann
Oh wir haben einen sub wieder am start ein german to orbit twitch prime
Dankeschön pock
Ich lade 3d runter
Ah ja noch besser noch besser wenn ich in 3d runter lade ist ja noch besser
Die history funktioniert irgendwie nicht
Ok also öffnen vlc
Huge fps massive fps aber es läuft
Ich meine es ist 3d 3d 60 fps
Ok wir machen mal zu wir machen mal zu
Wir laden das ganze noch mal runter in nicht 3d
Der ganze browser ruckelt 2d 2d 4k full hd
30 fps komm wir sind mal wir sind mal so nett und nur 30 fps ok
4k 30 fps ich weiß 4k 30 fps ist ja eigentlich ein witz für winos 98 aber wir machen es
mal
Der task manager den task manager gibt es in der form gar nicht
Wenn du den winos 890 task manager aufmachst dann kommt nur das da
Das ist der task manager
Dafür kannst du dir so aus dem processor explorer installieren und dann angucken
Ok wir müssen das alte zeug mal löschen sonst wird es sonst wird es hier zu voll
zack
alles löschen
da
kann da bleiben löschen löschen löschen
Raumplatz
Downloads
Datum können eigentlich alles löschen außer den aktuellen
So gucken wir uns mal an ob wir das schafft
So dann müssen wir noch mails einrichten müssen wir auch noch machen outlook express
mail
Machen wir gleich danach gucken ob das funktioniert
8 gigabyte festplatte haben wir ja auch gerade
brauchen nur irgendwie 150 mb oder so
woher ist diese stimme das ist in japan in koreanische text-to-speech service
also das hier
das ist in japanischer text-to-speech service
oder koreanischer
so download fertig
auf gehts angucken
das läuft besser
Leute 4k 30 fps minus 98
ich mein schnell ist was anderes ja
und das ist eher so gerade ein fps
aber allein schon dass das überhaupt läuft ist der witz ja
außerdem wissen wir ja dass zu viel fps ist auch nicht gut
ok das ist eindeutig die 3d die die die grafik ausgabe die probleme macht
weil wenn sich wenig im bild verändert läuft flüssig
sobald sich große bereiche im bild verändern ist
deswegen gucken wir mal ob wir das vielleicht umstellen können mit was der was ausgibt
video ausgabe hier erstmal advanced einstellungen machen
video ausgabe
keine ahnung was man hier am besten einstellt
standard
simple direct media layer video ausgabe ok was auch immer
das gleiche wie vorher
oder ist das was anderes was ich hier stream ausgabe
wo stellt man das hier ein was ab was er benutzt zum zum ausgeben
video gdi ausgabe ist das jetzt schneller
nicht wirklich oder eher schlechter und langsamer
ne das ist das ist mega kaputt windows ausgabe
ok probieren was anderes aus juff das ist das was für standard was standardmäßig
ist
im moment das hat gar gar kein bild jetzt
oje oje windows stop stop stop das kackt ab gleich
sieht man hier den ram der belegt ist sieht man hier wieviel ram noch belegt ist
ne anscheinend nicht ich hab keine ahnung vielleicht hab ich zu wenig ram
im zweifelsfall reboot
also das hat nicht richtig funktioniert
dann probieren wir jetzt mal simple direct media layer ausgabe
das hatten wir eben schon das hat eigentlich verhältnismäßig gut funktioniert
video speicherausgabe funktioniert nicht kommt keine ausgabe
wir finden schon irgendwas das flüssig läuft
ich hab vertrauen in vlc open gl video ausgabe jawoll wir haben zwar kein 3d aber
hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn das funktioniert
ein open gl geht natürlich nicht
alter mach mal stop wir haben wir haben keine wir haben nichts ist hier kein direct x oder
sonst was
das ist das nächste was wir machen wir installieren jetzt mal direct x
direct 3d ausgabe haben wir nicht
direkt x direkt 3d video ausgabe
dann stellen wir jetzt auf defaulten jetzt installieren wir direct x
da hatte ich doch hier irgendeinen download link hier
ja
3d
seiten sind alle immer so vertrauenserweckend aus wo man da was runterlädt
farbige ascii ausgabe ich weiß nicht ob das unter windows geht im vlc ob das dabei ist
so jetzt installieren wir erst mal direct x 9
dieses gui von windows das war damals auch schon echt grausam
wir stimmen zu wir stimmen bei allem zu gar kein problem
über alles müssen wir neu starten oder jawohl was sonst
war in der liste farbige ascii ausgabe ok das machen wir danach
da sind wir wieder mit neuem direct x
ja so war das damals alles auf den desktop entpacken wir alle auf weiterklicken reboot
fertig
ok vlc wir starten mal das starten noch mal das andere das afghan mw3
wow was mir am hintergrund passiert wolken strecken jawohl gut so mag ich das
und jetzt stellen wir mal um auf direkt x ausgabe
fack geht nicht es funktioniert nicht keine direkt x ausgabe mögliche
obwohl wir direkt x installiert haben
geht nicht ja da kommen wir jetzt mal ok da machen wir jetzt ascii ausgabe
so massive es ist mw2 seht ihr das es ist eindeutig mw2
ok das ist jetzt ascii 130 das kann man schlecht sehen
man muss es kleiner machen dann sieht es besser aus
umso kleiner umso besser
na nicht wirklich
umso kleiner umso besser in der regel das problem ist dass die bildpunkte
müssen mehr werden und die schriftzeichen müssen klein bleiben
schriftart vollbild
so was wie komme ich da jetzt wieder raus wie komme ich da jetzt wieder raus
ok strangen alle entfernt geht nicht
grip ist kaputt ich komme nicht mehr raus
oje oje haben wir noch klug gehabt
wo wohl oder wenn du aus ich will das dann titel mal anklicken
ich war man erkennt man erkennt sein vollbild machen auf keinen fall
ich will eigentlich welche schrift art kleiner machen und das fenster groß
lassen weil sonst ist ganz schön fail
guckt ich sag euch umso kleiner umso besser erkennt man es
jetzt sieht man ganz deutlich umso kleiner ist umso besser erkennt man es
jetzt bräuchte
na gut so und jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt gucken wir uns an zuletzt geöffnete
4k noch mal an
4k zu ascii ist noch langsamer als als 4k 4k rendern
cpu auslastung mal angucken
ein cpu kern ist dicht ein cpu kern ein cpu kern ist dicht
so und jetzt sagen wir wieder einstellung zurück auf die folgt
wir haben leider kein 3d unter hättet er hier 3d beschleunigung in der vm
könnten wir das bestimmt flüssig sogar wiedergeben
bitte so ein video mit gameplay ja das muss man echt machen
so also wir haben jetzt videos wiedergegeben erst mal alles löschen wir haben
die x installiert was uns irgendwie nix bringt erst mal papierkorb löschen
mails müssen wir noch einrichten
ich mein besser besser kannst du es nicht machen
wir haben den aktuellsten browser der irgendwie überhaupt nur möglich ist
vor allem er unterstützt kein 3d für winners 98 keine chance
keine chance
wir haben einen halbwegs aktuellen browser oder sagen wir mal so der aktuellste browser
der irgendwie möglich ist ja
oder wisst ihr was wir ausprobieren können
wir gucken mal ob wir nicht noch einen neueren firefox installiert kriegen
alter firefox schon wieder abgekackt legt das legt das das das liegt an no script
oder liegt das an no script das liegt bestimmt an no script
firefox das liegt bestimmt an no script als wir no script aus hatten war es überhaupt
kein problem
firefox 11 installs
breezes
ok mehr geht nicht wir haben den aktuellsten firefox
ok wir können kein aktuellen wir können in opera opera download winloss 98
ja winloss 98 was ist das für eine seite
monka monka things
zum glück haben wir no script angehabt
die download seite von denen ist im arsch aber opera 10 10 ist das letzte
file hippo pc welt gif pc welt jawoll pc welt nehmen wir
pc welt download ne gibts nicht
computer build download ja wir vertrauen computer build wir vertrauen computer build
gar kein problem
computer build download
file hippo gehört zur cc cleaner gut das heißt aber nicht dass das da drauf was da
drauf ist
computer build wie kann man downloaden von euch
wie wie downloadet man
wie downloadet man hier was computer build please ich will downloaden
sieht das irgendjemand wo kann man hier was downloaden das da bestimmt nicht oder
ne
streamst du morgen die apple keynote wie viel uhr
ok leider laden wir uns jetzt von file hippo runter
der große button ach da ich sehe sowas nicht ich blende sowas ich blende sowas direkt aus
19 uhr ja können wir machen
download starten ja
kennelerst risiko easy
ne ich will nicht opera 63 gbaited ich will opera 10 10 haben
was das die geht
kann ich hier was download ich will ich will ich will denn altes opera downloaden
ich will nicht opera 62 ich will opera 10 10
wo gibt es das braucht es jetzt zum download
alter warum warum
downloadet das immer irgendwie so ein bullshit
paper door dankeschön twitch prime
ich versuch das jetzt mal zu downloaden hiervon von meinem windows aus
das ist tibet das ist tibet
ok ich glaube da geht in der richtung geht da nicht mehr
was können wir denn sonst noch probieren
old version opera 10 10 ok das ist bestimmt irgendeine virus kacke
die seite sieht nicht so vertrauenserweckend aus ehrlich gesagt
old version dotnet wir suchen ob das vertrauenswürdig ist
am besten sucht man da einfach in ihrem forum einträge
nicht vertrauenserweckend aus ok hier nein fuck alter wo ist der download jetzt
was zum teufel wo ist der download achso klick hier
kann man das öffnen
ok das sieht tatsächlich nach opera aus ja weiter weiter
ok youtube läuft auf dem alten opera natürlich nicht
das ist klar aber das coole ist das opera von damals es war das letzte opera
mit mit eigener render engine das war noch kein chrome dementsprechend geht
hier auch nichts mehr ok dann testen wir mal da ob tagesschau
funktioniert was video tagesschau live auf gehts
eine Hawk
ok was kann man sonst noch probieren
was was könnte mail mail wollten wir ausprobieren
was opera 12 geht noch
altes counter strike ne wir haben kein 3d wir haben kein 3d das wird also alles was
da nichts brauche ich nicht nicht laufen können 3d pinball spielen old version opera 12
para for windows hier was ist das letzte was wir haben 12 war ja es war das letzte was es gab
genau download now genau hier dann installieren wir jetzt noch opera 12
ach ja genau da müssen wir kompatibilitäts modus einstellen und vorher deinstallieren wir mal den
alten opera oh der device uninstall wizard
wenn schon probieren wir werden aus me das nächste aus wie wäre es mit dem
alten shockwave game browser games ja flash haben installiert
gibt es gibt es noch flash browser games gibt es da noch irgendwas
kennt ihr mal eine halbwegs legit seite für flash browser games
funka ist kein flash ich weiß
probieren das wird nicht unterstützt
play it spiel affe das kenne ich noch kenne ich noch von frühen bubble shooter pro wollen wir
spielen unbedingt jetzt spielen bubble shooter pro
wir müssen flash spiele so flash flash tetris
oh
läuft schermut dungeon ist das denn ist flash kenne ich dich ist das flash
reinstall in your browser oh wow oder auch nicht
das windows wird gerade im hintergrund exploit ja wahrscheinlich zumindest sieht man davon nichts
wahrscheinlich sind wir schon in den botnetz drin also auf firefox ist
ok vielleicht lassen wir es einfach mal laden vielleicht vielleicht lassen wir es einfach mal
laden ok in der zwischzeit installieren wir den neuen opera ob der funktioniert
p
packen das jetzt einfach und es trägt 17
lul geht nicht
Ne, Chrome hab ich gelesen, läuft gar nicht.
Ach, ok, Moment, ist unsere Opera-Version etwa zu, zu...
Oh, jetzt ist Firefox RIP.
War unsere Opera einfach zu neu, was wir haben?
Downloads reagiert nicht, Taskbanden.
Jawoll, zack.
Ok, ähm, Old Versions Opera.
Was haben wir gesagt, 12?
Ne, was war das letzte, was diese eine gesagt hat?
1202 läuft angeblich noch.
1202, letzte Version.
Dialt X9 funktioniert, ja, aber wir haben halt keine Grafikkarte drin, damit wir was ausprobieren können.
Sonst könnten wir jetzt ein paar Sachen spielen.
Oh.
Dialt X9 haben wir schon installiert, hier, da ist es.
M, da ist es.
Opera, Pogu, ähm...
Tagesschau.de
Das ist immer so unser Standard-Test jetzt.
Ok, ist schon mal deutlich schneller als der 10er.
Deutlich schneller als der 10er.
Livestream, ah ja, die Livestream.
Der macht erst mal Tagesschau, Tagesschau 100 Sekunden, wollen wir haben.
Äh.
Ups.
Ne, Leute.
Ich glaube, da haben wir keine Chance.
Es sieht auch ganz schön kaputt aus, muss man mal sagen.
Das UI.
Ne, Funker geht garantiert nicht, das WebGL.
Aber ich muss sagen, bisher von allen Browsern läuft der eigentlich noch mit am besten.
Oh, oh, YouTube.
Aber so, immerhin die YouTube-Werbung mit Flash funktioniert schon mal, ja.
Das ist total hinüber.
Aber Flash-Games, wissen wir ja, dass die prinzipiell funktionieren, oder?
Flash.
Was haben wir mit Tetris, Tetris Flash oder so?
Flashladen sehen.
Ja, das geht.
Das war übrigens Fail, aber das funktioniert.
Also Flash läuft prinzipiell.
No, Reddit.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob es hier irgendein Video gibt.
Das RIP.
Twitter, ich weiß was.
Ach so, unser SSL ist zu alt.
Okay, keine Chance.
Also aktuelle Internetgeschichten kriegen wir nicht zum Laufen, können wir vergessen.
Mail wollten wir noch ausprobieren.
Posteingang.
Das Team, muss ich hier mal nachgucken, habe ich mir eingerichtet im letzten Stream.
Flash haben wir installiert, ja.
So eine Fake-Email-Adresse, die ich mir letztens angelegt habe.
Posteingang.
IMAP.
Das Ding kann schon IMAP.
Was?
IMAP, Google-Mail.
Alter, warum ist, wir haben Firefox kaputt gemacht.
Wir haben Firefox kaputt gemacht.
Everopera, auch gut.
IMAP, Google-Mail.
Okay, also.
IMAP-Server.
SSL erforderlich, MonkaS.
SSL erforderlich, das ist schon mal komplette RIP.
Funktioniert doch im Leben nicht.
Ja, schick mal den Link, moderner Browser.
Okay, ist das Passwort hier im Klartext?
Nein, zum Glück nicht, okay.
Kann ich den gerade rüber kopieren?
Ich meine, wenn ich leake, ist auch nicht wild, das ist ein Fake-Account.
Okay, im Leben geht das nicht.
Genau, funktioniert nicht.
Melon, was, Melon?
64.
Okay, kommen wir mal, das probieren wir mal aus.
Okay, Mail abrufen über allem, das geht schon mal nicht.
Was, Melon?
47, was ist das?
Browser.
Hey Melon.
Okay.
Ein Gigabyte RAM.
Okay, wo ist der Download?
Klick hier.
Mega, natürlich ist das outdated, was sonst?
Oh, die Seite will ich nicht aufmachen.
Ich trau mich nicht, die Seite aufzumachen.
Jawoll, safe.
Die haben wahrscheinlich schon 30 Milliarden Viren, oder?
Unzip, Right-Click, K-Melon-X, okay.
Dann auf Kompatibilität, will aus 2000 umstellen.
Gigibaited.
Geht nicht.
Aber gemacht.
Gigibaited.
Ja, Moment, hier müssen wir noch Updates installieren von.
Muss noch Updates installiert werden von.
Download Now.
Mirror, jawoll.
Cacks Beta, klingt auch wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend, Cacks Beta.
Aber gut, ich mein, die VM kann irgendwo hin.
Was zum Teufel macht Cacks Beta?
Unzip, ach so, man soll das einfach drüber kopieren.
Man muss das hier nehmen, den Inhalt kopieren und dann nach die doppelpunschte Windows, dann die Körne da rein kopieren.
Alle ersetzen, voll.
Moment, wo hab ich denn jetzt den Kram nochmal entpackt?
Woran hab ich jetzt diesen komischen Browser nochmal entpackt?
Da.
Reboot.
Max, vergiss den technischen Sellout nicht.
Stimmt, du hast recht, ich hab den Sellout vergessen.
Also Leute, wenn wir hier Primers am Start haben,
wenn euch der Stream gefällt und ihr es auch nicht wusstet,
man kann mit Amazon Prime seinen Twitch-Account verknüpfen und bekommt dann einen Sub im Monat kostenlos.
Alle Vorteile für einen selbst und für den Streamer und es kostet einem nix.
I'm Rick James, Bitch, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Okay, ich hab so die Bedenken, dass wir diesen komischen Browser nicht zum...
Oh, das ist was anderes jetzt.
Aha.
Okay, funktioniert nicht, für den Arsch.
Wir haben's gerippt.
Power off.
Wir haben's zerstört, okay.
Naja, gut, was willst du machen, ne?
War trotzdem nice, huge brain.
Jetzt Windows ME.
Muss ich mal gucken, ob es dort einen Windows ME so gibt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Windows ME.
Ja, gibt es hier.
War die logische Weiterentwicklung von 98 irgendwo.
Das war nicht schlechter als 98.
Das war genauso scheiße wie 98 im Endeffekt.
Weiß gar nicht, warum das so gehatet wurde.
Bei wenigstens waren standardmäßig Zippen und Entzippen dabei.
Okay Leute, jetzt haben wir ganz schön rumgefrickelt hier im Stream.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir uns 20 Milliarden Viren oder so
eingefangen auf Windows 98.
Deswegen...
Gut, wie soll das auf den Hausrechner kommen, ne?
Es gibt da theoretisch die Möglichkeit, aus der VM auszubrechen.
Aber den Windows 98 Viren war besten Wille nicht zu.
Als mein erster Switch war abgeholt überhaupt, nice.
Ich glaube, es hat nicht geklappt.
Ich sehe nur.
Bis kein Zap, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe es gebeten.
Wie viele Emote-Slots ich jetzt eigentlich habe.
Ah, Emoats? Ja also warte mal, ich habe jetzt Emoatslots, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15 Emoatslots und 16, 17 mit Tier 2, Tier 3.
Also 16 Emoatslots und davon habe ich sagenhafte 4 Emoats, finde ich schon. Und das Schlimme ist es abgrenzen muss, ne.
Oberskübel, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pock.
Ich muss mal gucken wie viele Abos ich heute gemacht habe, weil heute Morgen waren es relativ viele, mal gucken ob das so weiter gegangen ist.
58, das ist nicht übel und der Tag ist dann immer vorbei.
Mal gucken wie viele haben wir jetzt, 7, 8, 6, es ist auch gar noch ein paar mehr geworden, sogar 63 oder so haben wir jetzt.
Pickmaps, stimmt nicht. Guck mal und wisst ihr was das beste ist? Ich hatte ja die letzten Monate, also die letzten Jahre eigentlich, weil ich nichts gemacht habe, hatte ich ja immer, hatte ich ja immer De-Abo's, ja.
Hier habe ich was gemacht, hier gab es wieder ordentlich Subs, ich hatte ja immer De-Abo's, weil ich habe halt nichts hochgeladen und im Prinzip habe ich immer, habe ich einfach inaktive Konten oder Leute die keinen Bock mehr hatten zu warten oder so, sind halt, sind halt abgehauen, ja ist doch verständlich.
Wo hast du den Chromium her? Den habe ich, ja von dieser Adresse, die, den Namen kann ich aber nicht aussprechen, GWOZ13Cruschenrender gepostet hat.
Ja das ist legit, da habe ich das auch, ja. So und das beste ist, dass wir jetzt nach zwei Wochen ungefähr, ja das stimmt nicht was da steht hier, das ist, es ist nicht 72 und es ist nicht 1100 Euro.
Wenn man mal die Sellout, die Sellout Sachen weglässt, ja. So und wir haben es, ich habe es jetzt quasi geschafft innerhalb von zwei Wochen, die quasi wieder komplett auf plus minus null mit den Negativ-Abo's zu kommen.
Das heißt alles was jetzt kommt geht wieder aufwärts. Playing like a genius Twitch Prime. Danke. 300k sind drin, ja mein Ziel ist ja, dass ich irgendwie 300k schaffe.
Das ist nämlich so eine Sache, die wollte ich schon lange mal, wollte ich schon lange haben, 300k. Leider hat YouTube irgendwie kein ordentliches, kein ordentliches so Premium-Programm, ne.
Du hast deine 100.000 Abos und du hast die Millionen Abos-Buttons, Play-Buttons. Das wäre cool, wenn es doch so irgendwie einen 200.000 oder einen 300.000, einen 400.000 oder so.
Wenn man den ganzen Sellout-Gramm mitrechnet und so, ja, dann schon. Allerdings reine YouTube Sachen, was die hier ausrechnen, es ist mehr da dran, reine YouTube, als da dran.
Ganz große Streamer bekommen auch Pro-Follow-Geld, das glaube ich nicht. Warum sollten die Pro-Follow-Geld bezahlen?
Soundtrip? Sound geht immer noch. Echt Pro-Follower? Na gut, da müssen die schon so Ninja-mäßig sein. Aber Pro-Follower zu bezahlen ist irgendwie merkwürdig.
Der Ghost Recon Video wollte keiner sehen. Aber das ist mir egal. Ich hab alles gemacht, was ich machen konnte letztendlich, ja.
Ich hab das Video extra übers Wochenende, obwohl ich andere Videos hochladen wollte, die viel mehr Klicks gekriegt haben. Guck mal, das Ghost Recon Video ist drei Tage hoch und das andere ist noch nicht mal ganz ein Tag oben und hat schon irgendwie das Doppelte fast an Views.
Und ich hab alles gemacht, was ich konnte, ja. Ich hab's hochgeladen, zweieinhalb Tage stehen lassen, das Video. Ist halt einfach was, was bei mir nicht so viel interessiert, aber letztendlich unterm Strich ist mir egal, weil Sellout ist, der ist auch real, auch mit 12k.
Hab ich eigentlich meinen Link richtig gemacht da unten? Ja, zum Glück. Mein Link passt. Warum kostet das Game eigentlich 109 Euro? Was ist denn da los? Ach so, weil es die Ultimate Edition ist.
Ja gut, aber was kostet die normale? Okay, was genau ist da jetzt dabei, das 60 Euro wert ist? Beta Zugang? Irgendeinen Pack? Ja gut, wenn man Fan der Serie ist vielleicht, ja. Ich würd mir wenn schon das normale kaufen.
Ghost Recon Future Soldier, gab's das? Kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern. Tatsächlich. Das letzte Ghost Recon, was ich gespielt hab, war Advanced Warfighter auf der Xbox, schon uralt.
Ich bin am überlegen, mit wem ich alles ein Video machen könnte, weil so wie das auf YouTube heutzutage ist, so ein bisschen Cross Promotion ist immer nicht verkehrt.
Will ich auch nicht so sehr, dass die Leute, die es finden, beziehungsweise die, die extra in die Comments gehen, in die Beschreibung gehen, anklicken, dann herkommen und dann beim Video auftauchen, beim Stream auftauchen, das ist okay, aber ich will nicht random gefunden werden auf Twitch.
Äh, was wollt ich grad sagen? Äh, fuck, jetzt hab ich vergessen. Ach genau, mit wem ich alles aufnehmen soll. Also mit dem Solution hab ich mir schon überlegt, da machen wir was, haben wir auch schon kurz drüber geschrieben.
Aber ansonsten ist ja von denen, die ich kenne, gar keiner mehr wirklich am Start, ja. Wer ist denn da, wer ist denn da noch da, wo sich vor allem für beide lohnt irgendwo, ja. Jetzt muss ich für den anderen irgendwie noch halbwegs lohnen.
Für mich natürlich auch lohnen. Ja, der andere Solution, vielleicht, vielleicht, aber der hat ja auch nicht wirklich viele. Der hat irgendwie einen neuen Channel gemacht mit, keine Ahnung, 300, 300 Abos oder so. Aber das wäre noch eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Ich meine, ich überleg nur gerade, wo es halt für beide Seiten richtig, richtig sinnvoll wäre. Der Niko, ja der Niko. Also erstens glaube ich nicht, dass der, oder vielleicht, vielleicht würde es der Niko noch machen, aber das hat ja null Schnittmenge miteinander mehr.
Der Niko macht sein Lifestyle Zeug und ich mach hier Technik, Technik Gameplay Kram, das hat ja null Schnittmenge mehr. CW Ravenblood, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Die Prime. Dino, den kenne ich nicht. Sag ja von denen, die ich kenne, es kann doch einer da. Vielleicht von denen, vielleicht, vielleicht von denen, die jetzt ein bisschen größer sind und die damals halt auch bei mir geguckt haben.
Aber da weiß ich halt nicht, wer so richtig und wir kennen uns auch nicht so wirklich, ja.
Zemper Video. Nö, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was wir da zusammen machen sollten. Außerdem, mit dem M-Core mache ich auch auf jeden Fall was. Außerdem ist der wahrscheinlich nicht so der Zusammenaufnehmen Typ.
Ja, das wäre eine Idee, das könnte man tatsächlich machen, den kenne ich sogar noch. Das könnte man machen, aber da müsste irgendwie, Jesus, genau, da muss ich erstmal ein tiefer gelegtes Auto holen.
Slot Machine ballern, genau. Uptick Rush, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher, also ob er will, dann müsste man irgendwie ein Thema finden, was irgendwie passt und wirklich großartig kennen tun wir uns ja auch nicht.
Wir haben uns, wir haben uns mal fünf Minuten bei der Gamescom vor ein paar Jahren gesehen, das ist alles. Was findest du besser, Firefox oder Chrome? Ja, ich benutze zum größten Teil Chrome mittlerweile, allerdings finde ich Firefox besser.
Xeroxino, Stufe 1, Dankeschön. Pornos, jedes Erd, Quatsch. Ich glaube, das ist nicht das, was die Leute sehen wollen, außerdem können die sich das vor allem halt gucken.
Da muss ich nichts zu erzählen. Ja, gibt nicht so viel. John Rage, kenne ich nicht, aber, also wir kennen uns nicht persönlich, aber mit dem hat man ein paar mal auf Twitter geschrieben, also man hat sich zumindest schon mal gelesen.
Der Fedor spielt jetzt Poker. Ja, das andere ist noch am Start. Also es sind nicht mehr viele, so richtig viele da eigentlich.
Der Puster, weiß nicht, ob der. Der Felix, ja mit dem wollte ich mal irgendwas zum Thema Smartphone, vor Jahren schon aufnehmen, aber wirklich gut kennen tun wir uns auch nicht. Es ist halt wirklich keiner mal so richtig da.
Was für Vorteile bietet Twitch App für den Desktop? Keine Ahnung, keine. Twitch guckt man am besten im Browser mit BetterTwitchTV oder FrankerFacesZ, wobei mir FrankerFacesZ wie lieber ist als BetterTwitchTV.
Was ist eigentlich mit Elotrix passiert? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Macht der noch was? HDX oder wie hieß das?
Zwei Jahre. Gut, der hat keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube, kann ich auch nachvollziehen.
Der hat halt keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube, was ich voll verstehen kann.
Oh, der ist ausgemacht.
Ja Leute, also ich hab jetzt gleich was hier zu essen am Start, ich muss jetzt was futtern. Wir gucken mal, ob es was gibt, den ich hosten kann.
Erst mal schauen, ob da irgendjemand hier, den ich sonst folge am Start ist.
Wer ist das gute Twitch Plugin? FFZ, das da. Das da. Das ist das gute Twitch Plugin. Ja, mittlerweile sogar eine History, richtig nice.
Der Rayst, der ist ganz schön eifrig am... Was für eine Sprache programmiert der eigentlich? Ah, wenigstens bis zum Glück nicht Java.
Ich gucke geradeaus, ob es irgendwas gibt.
Host hier mit null Zuschauern. Kennt ihr euch noch an den erinnern, den wir gehostet haben, der keine Hose anhatte?
Das war was ey.
Ach ja Leute, ich wusste, also morgen. Wann ist das mit der Apple Keynote? Apple Keynote 2019. Wann ist das hier? 19 Uhr, ne? 10. September.
Da gibt es noch irgendeine deutsche News dazu. Indian Express.
Ok, das mache ich mir gleich mal. Firefox. Firefox. Geh auf. Da. Da. Lass mich das nicht vergessen. Und ich schreibe mir das ganz fett auf, dass ich das morgen nicht vergesse.
Hast du einen Tipp, warum ich in Scoop manchmal Apps nicht starten kann? Nee. Pibanator, gibt es den noch? Ok, also schreibe ich mir auf hier. Apple Keynote. Das gucken wir uns morgen zusammen an.
Und können uns anschauen, ob es wieder Monitorhalterungen gibt für 200 Euro.
Habt ihr gerade auch einen Mail-Sound gehört? Hab ich angehört wie ein Mail-Sound gerade oder? Oder bilde ich mir das schon ein? Wo kam das her? Das ist bestimmt hier im Video drin.
Weil ich habe eigentlich nichts auf, was irgendwelche Mail-Sounds machte.
Achso, von der Xbox. Ah, verstehe.
Wie kam das da her gerade? Echt so oft. Ja, die haben sich von Windows 98 vor einem, haben die sich eingeschlichen.
Das ist immer so random Zeug auf einmal auf Plop von irgendwelchen Treibern.
Was macht Killer Junge zur Zeit so? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ok Leute, dann sehen wir uns morgen zu Apple Keynote, gucken was es da gibt. Wahrscheinlich sind sie wieder sich extrem am selbst abfeiern. Aber was auch sonst.
Und wir sehen uns bis morgen, machts gut, CU. Oder noch Outro-Musik, wollt ihr noch Outro-Musik?
Bis dann, CU.
Outro-Musik